Warner Brothers has announced that
Batman returned to Arkham will not meet
its previously announced July 26th
release date and as of publishing a new
release date has not been specified I'm
Lucy and welcome to your improved
lighting gamespot news updates posting
on The WB games forum a company
representative said after reviewing the
progress of the project the team at WB
games has decided to delay the release
of Batman returned to Arkham to give the
team a virtuous games additional time to
deliver a polished batman arkham game
experience we do not have a release date
yet and we'll be sure to communicate
that once we are sure the game will be
ready we know this is disappointing news
but we feel the extra time will allow
the team to create the best gaming
experience for our fans following
multiple leaks Batman returned to Arkham
was officially announced in May it will
include remastered versions of Arkham
Asylum and Arkham City and in addition
to the base games players will receive
all game via extras and downloadable
content overall Warner Brothers said
players can expect improved graphics and
upgraded models environments lighting
effects and shaders while the original
games were powered by the Unreal Engine
3 3 masters are being developed by
virtuous games using Unreal Engine 4
which was previously worked on heavy
rains ps4 version and contributed to
uncharted for thieves and you can also
see some of the company's work in action
in star wars the force awakens so when
do you think we'll be returning to
Arkham let me know in the comments below
or come find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy
James games for more Batman adventures
keep it gamespot
you